[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day it's the
end of another long week on the Internet
let's talk about a few things twitter is
going crazy over this hyper-realistic
bulldog cake Ainsley could you pull that
up so this is from a London Baker who
goes by the name of the cake illusionist
it's just a cake Thank You Ainsley
that's good do we love this do you want
one they start at two hundred and fifty
pound per cake which is what like three
hundred and twenty dollars everyone's
upset that it looks like a dog no one's
upset that it tastes like a dog you know
if its moist I feel like you all want
these delicious amok skates and then it
looks like a dog and suddenly animal
control like relax people had a child on
a cake for their birthday all the time a
picture of real life yeah they're like I
want the face important than kids faces
so there are cakes where there's babies
baked into the cakes what know the
animals like is one of the signs that
you're like a serial killer right or
that you're like it is Hanna and so it's
like this is just like a gateway drug to
serial killing I lack people who buy
these cakes
you guys are so dramatic it's a it looks
like a dog it's weird she cut it face
first that's weird
it's yeah and there's a little tear that
strawberry teal cheer - you're you're
also all meat-eaters though right yeah
know what that was a pig and you're
cutting into a face yum yum yeah I don't
see the pig that I mean you should pork
cheek is delicious food I just think
it's weird I think it's weird that
they're making these cakes I think some
art should not exist you're
supposed to eat it looks like that okay
people would be like this doesn't even
look like a dog like this is shooty
artwork and because it's so good people
are like oh we're eating the dog
complains about something get over it it
looks delicious
so dramatically chill I'm gonna make a
cake that looks just like it when we
heat it just look like Ryan said art
should exist
Hannah I want to throw through our next
story now movie pass has run into some
trouble
most recently they're announcing a 50%
price hike so taking the monthly
subscription cost to 1495
and an even more limited choice of the
film's you can see his movie pass over
people who subscribe to it already I
think Jordan does it does how are you
feeling I mean I have to mean I did
abuse movie pass in the sense of like I
was in Times Square I need to take a
and then go take a
you know you can just ask to go use the
bathroom oh is that the primary reason
why you're upset is because it'll be a
little bit harder it is I hate upfront
I get upfront and I've seen probably
like four times what I paid them already
in movie tickets it's been worth it for
you totally worth it if it goes away it
goes away it was doomed from the start
no one thought like oh this thing is
gonna work it's what I had a friend
recently buy stock they're like it's at
25 cents I'm like yeah that's not good
everyone buys now I mean it's just a
good buying opportunity at the moment to
buy now it's at like $7,000 right now oh
my god just trying to sell yours you
should just try to sell mine cuz then no
that admits 44 our first-time viewers
Jordan famously bought a bunch of
Bitcoin at the peak when is that like
20,000 and December 17 he's lost
thousands of dollars he would love it if
you would all go buy bitcoins to help
bring the price back thousands of
dollars you have disposable incomes
pretty good yeah
yeah I'm good at saving money and I blew
it all right wait you just said you're
good at saving okay thank you yeah and I
only listen to the first part of the
sentence I went to go see eighth grade
at BAM the other day and it wasn't that
was the first day it was down like they
ran out of money to buy tickets for
people and it was just 30 people just
like refreshing this game like drones
yep a couple in Heroes went to the box
office and we're like we're just gonna
buy a ticket and like you know it's too
expensive I would have for sure you
already there you made your plan that we
just went back to my apartment so funny
buying at the peak is actually not a bad
thing because there's gonna be another
peak later here here et speaking of
Peaks I hate that already our next story
oh wow I'm sorry I feel bad about Mia
Khalifa she's a former porn star and
she's also yeah she was only a porn star
for three months in 2014 but now that's
kind of really knows her but she's the
host of a show and while she was at a
hockey game Aynsley can you post that
photo three months that Islander must
have been I mean she looked like she
aged in a few movies - oh my Wow at a
hockey game the puck hit one of her
breasts and ruptured one of the implants
this was a couple months ago and she
just told reporters that she now has to
have surgery to replace this implant
somewhere it shouldn't exist
now jordan you brought this story to our
attention was about this story that you
felt like we needed to talk about today
is cool story is like cool she's good to
look at sometimes yeah it's good stuff
she's the host of sports balls
a video podcast on the roosterteeth glad
we plug that come to my show Friday
night at the secret law Jordans on it
I like this comment here garbage dot NHL
said deflated booth yeah kept read I
just got less and less sensor it was
just like porn I just stopped caring a
few minutes like I'm done I feel like
that implant might have saved her life
[Laughter]
over and the article said that the puck
was going 80 miles per hour
oh my god I always said it women don't
belong in sports alright I feel the way
to she's safe
[Laughter]
now we're gonna do a thing where a
Hannah does a segment calls cheers to
you check it out right now hi I'm Hannah
Dickinson and this is cheers to you
where I'm kicking off my first round of
the weekend by cheering to all the
people and stories that encouraged me to
drink Cheers steam movie pass for
collecting my money up front and then
going out of business I'm pissed
even though you weren't the first app to
introduce me to a bad idea I wasn't
drunk enough for you to me like that
cheers to you Harry Potter for turning
38 nice to see Hollywood finally aging a
man even if he is completely fictional
oh and cheers to Dolph Ziggler for also
turning 38 I can't wait until you're old
enough to finally consider dating me
cheers to you Kim Kardashian for
slimming down to a hundred and nineteen
pounds and having your family call your
anorexic you're only 19 pounds away from
them calling you Kendall cheers to you
Chrissy Teigen for showing off your mom
body whatever bitch what took you two
pregnancies takes me one hour at a Hyatt
continental breakfast Oh cheers to you
Tiffany Haddish for claiming your backup
career as a sex ed teacher well thank
God you became an actress under our
current government we can't risk
fifteen-year-old girls thinking she
ready
I mind it's too white for that I love
you TIFF are you gonna buy one of those
cakes don't would you eat it first like
they did if I'm gonna buy a cake of
something that looks real I'm going in
face-first you're gonna spend $300 I
made out of cake well would you inside
leave me that what kind of cake would
you be ice cream ice cream cake
you'll be I think questions like that so
interview questions you know it does
tells you nothing about a person what
kind of cake right right would be a
grumpy case it tells you nothing about a
person yes
what kind of cake no I'd be a cake that
loves my family just so you know mate
you'll be an angel food cake Oh shitty
cake what a turn be a toilet cake I was
they put did you pee on in the toilet
another question
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you